si on pouvait recouvrir la terre de
panneaux solaires il nous suffirait
juste d'une toute petite heure pour que
l'humanité est assez d'énergie pour plus
d'un an le potentiel semble énorme voilà
pourquoi un projet comme desertec serait
va recouvrir le sahara de ces panneaux
mais un que ce tout petit carré
permettrait de subvenir aux besoins du
monde entier c'est beau hein mais si
c'était la pire décision à prendre je
rigole pas en le solaire a beau être à
la mode glorifier sur les plateaux télé
vous dire la vérité une technologie
ancienne on en voyait des gens
1878 temps depuis tout ce temps ça n'a
pas été massivement adopté et ce n'est
pas que par paresse politique la science
va nous aider à mieux comprendre
pourquoi les panneaux solaires ont-ils
un rendement aussi faible vous le savez
un panneau solaire ne convertit pas 100
% de l'énergie reçue pour un panneau
entrée de gamme on est seulement 1 16
19% et 20% si vous y mettez un peu les
moyens c'est pas fou on est d'accord
mais qu'est ce qui nous empêche
d'atteindre ces 100 % tant espérée pour
le savoir zoom sur un panneau et ses
millions de petites cellules
photovoltaïques rien de
technologiquement très complexe on a
juste à se servir des propriétés du
silicium une matière un peu particulière
puisque quand à photons de lumière le
touch savall excité et libéré un
électron de l'électricité quoi si le
rendement n'est pas à 100% c'est à cause
des recommandations électrons trou en
gros l'électron libre va plutôt chercher
à se reconnecter un autre at home plutôt
que de se laisser aspirer dans les fils
électriques un phénomène amplifié par la
chaleur au dessus de 25 degrés les
rendements chute en vibrant plus fort
les atomes rencontre plus facilement des
électrons libres toujours ce problème de
tron c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu
installer des panneaux solaires en plein
désert pendant l'été n'est pas forcément
la solution idéale ajoute à ça la
poussière qui bloque la lumière les
verres protecteurs qui réfléchit une
partie des rayons et bien sûr la
déperdition électrique dans les styles
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que le
rendement maximal que la science peut
théoriquement atteindre sera toujours
limité à 33 7% c'est la limite de choc
licquoise heures malheureusement cette
question du rendement n'est pas le seul
problème il y aussi la durée de vie
minimale des panneaux solaires 30 en
moyenne selon les constructeurs et ça
c'est sans prendre en compte l'usure car
chaque année les rendements baissent
jusqu'à
pour cent ce à cause des micro fissures
provoquées par le temps la chaleur et le
froid c'est pour toutes ces raisons que
le solaire n'est pas aussi rentable
conte la danse j'ai travaillé dans la
vente de panneaux solaires et
l'argumentaire qu'on donnait aux petites
mamies dès qu'elle ferait des économies
qu'elle serait auto suffisante en cas de
crise ou guerre civile on sait jamais
avec tout ce qu'on voit sur bfm tv sauf
qu'on disait pas toute la vérité
prononcez youtuber américain qui a
installé des solar roof d'elon musk pour
30000 dollars sa facture annuelle a été
réduite de 2000 $
cool mais en prenant en compte plusieurs
lits lui il faudra quand même 20 ans
pour rentabiliser l'investissement
sans compter la batterie à 12000 dollars
qui ne l'a pas prise estimant n'avoir
pas besoin de stockage il aurait fallu
la changer tous les dix ans encore un
coup dur sur la facture ok en france
c'est bien plus avantageux mais c'est
parce que c'est subventionnés par l'état
et milliers d'euros d' aide pour
financer vos installations et un rachat
de votre production électrique jusqu'à
quatre fois le prix du marché
malheureusement un peu partout dans le
monde c'est la fin de la fête pour ses
subventions publiques mais soyons
honnêtes c'est compensé par la baisse
prodigieuse du coût de cette énergie est
ce que des pays ont déjà réussi leur
transition vers le solaire
bochimans le monde découvre avec effroi
qu'un tchernobyl moderne est encore
possible un peu dans la panique
l'allemagne décide d'accélérer sa sortie
du nucléaire on va plutôt construire un
max d'éoliennes et des parcs solaires 20
millions de mètres carrés l'équivalent
d'un cinquième de paris devenu bleu fluo
regardez ici près de berlin quatre cent
soixante mille panneaux qui remplace des
terres jadis agricole sauf que
l'allemagne c'est pas un pays réputé
pour ses petits mojito ce au bord d'une
plage ensoleillée
do béton froid grisaille et pluie en
pleine zone bleue sachez quand même que
malgré une idée reçue même par mauvais
temps les panneaux solaires marche juste
que leurs capacités diminuent le vrai
problème sous ces latitudes plus tôt les
nuits d'hiver et les 20 heures c'est
votre dîner en famille vous allumez le
four le chauffage la télévision mais
dehors est tout noir vos panneaux ne
fonctionne plus c'est ce qu'on appelle
le problème de l'intermittence quand les
gens ont le plus besoin d'électricité et
là où on en produit le moins il y a des
solutions on n'en parlera mais elle
coûte très cher aux citoyens allemands
sur leurs factures d'électricité c'est
deux fois plus élevé qu'en france où un
service catastrophique en plus de ça en
grosses coupures se produisent
régulièrement plus de 162 milles dans le
pays rien qu'en 2020 l'économie est
paralysée l'état obligé d'indemniser les
entreprises un autre problème et c'est
ou l'allemagne fabrique tels ces
panneaux en 2011 ils étaient encore les
leaders mondiaux de la fabrication avec
l'entreprise piocelle mais depuis elle a
été rachetée par les sud coréens
aujourd'hui c'est la chine qui domine
totalement le marché sur les dix
principaux fabricants 900 asiatique un
seul américain 0 européen alors ok ça a
eu l'énorme avantage de faire chuter le
prix des panneaux solaires depuis 10 ans
et ça oblige à les importer la
délocaliser et à détruire sa balance
commerciale sans oublier la pollution
que cause des bateaux plein de panneaux
qui font le tour du monde et l'écologie
parlons-en pour relever le défi de
l'intermittence l'allemagne avait besoin
d'une énergie pilotable plus stable au
lieu de compenser avec le nucléaire à la
choisille le charbon et surtout le gaz
vont massivement apporté depuis
l'étranger plus de 50% de son mix avant
2018 grâce est en train de changer
malgré tout l'allemagne reste toujours
le pays le plus pollueur d'europe et le
7e mondial s'est pas franchement une
réussite on peut le dire même si c'est
le prix à payer pour être les pionniers
les premiers à l'avoir tenté et grâce à
eux on a pu corriger beaucoup des
défauts observés en vérité les seules
expériences solaire qui ont marché c'est
celle qui sont fait à l'échelle de
petites communautés sans grosse usine
est loin du rythme effréné les grandes
villes ainsi au japon dans une banlieue
de la haye dota les 553 foyers ont pu
être alimenté à 100 % photovoltaïque
avec des batteries pour que ça marche
même la nuit la ville de fully sawa elle
en partenariat avec panasonic prévoit de
construire d'immenses lotissement
totalement sus tenable une autre
solution qui marche et d'importer
l'énergie solaire depuis l'étranger
singapour par exemple afin d'atteindre
son objectif de neutralité carbone va
faire construire l'un des plus grand
parc photovoltaïque du monde pas chez
eux ya pas de place mais en australie à
plus de trois mille sept cent cinquante
kilomètres ça oblige 2-1 à nîmes ans
câble et vous imaginez il y à pas mal de
déperdition en cours de route sans
compter que singapour deviendra
diplomatiquement dépendante de
l'australie des pays voisins qui
pourraient couper le câble en cas de
désaccord
soyons honnêtes sur ce point c'est un
problème qu'on a déjà en bien pire avec
les énergies fossiles et 15 solaire
locale permettrait d'éviter la pollution
cacher des panneaux solaires on l'entend
souvent dans les médias les panneaux
solaires pollue parce qu'ils les
utilisent des terres à sa tête une idée
reçue la quasi totalité sont juste à
base de silicium aluminium cuivré
platique la terreur ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas rang on a même utilisé des
produits cancérigènes dans certains
panneaux qui en cassant finissait par
polluer les sols pour tous a été
remplacé depuis par contre veut pas dire
que tout est rose le silicium
l'ingrédient principal c'est du made in
china ils ont 70% de la production
mondiale or il n'utilise pas d'énergie
verte pour le minage des docks 9
millions de tonnes de charbon qui sont
brûlés pour produire 7 millions de
tonnes de silicium fatalement ça plombe
pas mal le bilan carbone du solaire 41
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure à titre
de comparaison une centrale à charbon en
aimer 21 fois plus le nucléaire et
l'éolien trois fois moins
encore améliorer les méthodes de
production pour être au top niveau mais
ça va dans le bon sens un deuxième
problème c'est celui de la déforestation
le solaire ça demande beaucoup de place
en gironde le projet horizon au prévoit
la destruction de 10 millions de mètres
carrés de forêt pour installer le plus
grand parc solaire européen évidemment
les amoureux de la nature sont furieux
pour que l'europe soit 100% solaire il
faudrait raser un trou de cette taille
la france pourrait prévoir d'ici 2050 de
construire plus de 1800 kilomètres
carrés de photovoltaïque soit le
département de l'essonne quid maintenant
du recyclage tant espéré parce que
personne n'en parle mais en 2045
commencera ce qu'on appelle la grande
vague des déchets solaire 78 millions de
tonnes de panneaux seront devenus hors
d'usagé 800 tours eiffel en tonnes de
déchets heureusement 94% des matériaux
sont recyclables il ya même une loi qui
oblige les fabricants à reprendre vos
panneaux en fin de vie pour les recycler
comme dans cette usine à aix en provence
c'est cool mais c'est très gourmands en
énergie en plus d'être un peu polluant à
cause de la sirène d'éthylène vinyle et
il n'y a pas que ça les batteries sont
aussi à recycler au bout de dix ans
elles sont kini et ça on a
malheureusement toujours pas trouvé de
solution des chercheurs pour quelques
pistes et il faut vraiment espérer qu'on
y arrive alors pourquoi le solaire est
autant la mode et ce qu'il n'existerait
pas un lobby du solaire attention il en
existe pour toutes les énergies et celui
du pétrole est de loin le plus puissant
plus d'un milliard de dollars de
lobbying afin d'influencer les lois en
2015 le guardian relevait même que les
grosses compagnies pétrolières avaient
pris des positions dominantes dans les
principales associations industriels
chargés de promouvoir le solaire et
l'éolien blue est carrément dans la
bergerie il articles plus que c'est pour
ralentir le solaire et promouvoir le gaz
mais laissez-moi verser 2 secondes dans
une sorte de théorie du complot est ce
que ça serait pas un vrai plan de
méchants de films de promouvoir une
énergie qui ne marche pas tout seul pour
qu'au final on soit obligé de revenir au
gaz et au charbon comme ce qui se passe
en allemagne comment comprendre sinon
les investissements des géants du
pétrole dans cette énergie exagère
évidemment
lobbying anti solaire est réel est
encore très puissants aux états unis
mais leur position s'affaiblissent le
solaire est en train de gagner et c'est
pas toujours pour les bonnes raisons si
l'europe le pousse autant c'est en
assumant que c'est l'énergie du
libéralisme car oui seul un étape
construire un barrage où une centrale
nucléaire alors que le solaire s'est
ouvert à n'importe quel industriel des
libéraux font pression pour ouvrir le
marché en ces temps quand même d'abord
bien gavé des énormes marchés publics
qui se sont ouverts quand des
milliardaires comme elon musk ou warren
buffett investisse dans cette énergie
quand daniel crétine qui magna de
l'énergie fossile rachète le monde et
marianne ne faut pas être dupe sur la
capacité de ces gens à financer du
lobbying pour ou contre telle ou telle
énergie regardez seulement le nombre de
youtube heures qui parle de
renouvelables en ce moment nous mêmes on
a été contacté par trois agences pour
les promouvoir ont ils nous ont pas
retenu engins peu je précise un rien de
mal à faire ça ça va même plutôt dans le
bon sens je trouve idiot utile dans
l'équation ça sera les politiques les
élus locaux sont généralement pour le
solaire car il ya dans leur commune un
tissu de pme qui pose les panneaux sur
les toits les présidentiables eux
peuvent facilement promettre la création
de millions d'emplois car c'est vrai que
tout casser pour tout reconstruire a
fait du boulot maintenant est ce qu'on
n'est pas face à un mirage qui
multipliera les projets foireux certains
politiciens disent haut et fort sur tous
les plateaux télé que le solaire et
l'éolien sont maintenant les énergies
les moins chères c'est un peu exagéré
quand même oui les prix du sol air chute
car plus on produit moins ça coûte sauf
que le nucléaire anciens est toujours en
tête si les nouveaux réacteurs repères
sont si chers c'est que c'est les
premiers à être construits et qu'ils
n'ont pas les mêmes économies d'échelle
que le solaire dans le solaire justement
on oublie souvent dans les calculs qu'il
faudra changer une grande partie de
l'infrastructure électrique du pays
et pas adapté à l'intermittence et la
décentralisation n'aurait besoin de
passer à ce qu'on appelle un réseau
smart grid jean marc jancovici considère
que la france 100% solaire qui traite
6400 milliards de plus qu'un scénario
nucléaire et comme greenpeace il en
riant un peu les chiffres dans son sens
non si on veut de la partialité il faut
regarder du côté du rapport rte qui a
mis tous les acteurs autour de la table
pour calculer le coût de l'énergie en
2050 dans le scénario le plus optimiste
est avantageux pour le solaire ça reste
le plus cher de tous 14 milliards de
plus en plus d'impliquer d'un peu serré
la ceinture de changer nos modes de vie
et de passer à ce qu'on appelle la
décroissance ça peut être un bon projet
politique et fois trop nette avec ce que
cela implique quels sont les progrès
technologiques que fera le solaire à
l'avenir les premiers panneaux solaires
au silicium a vanté en 1953 n'avait que
6 % en un an devant lui ça plus que
triplé mais malheureusement l'avenir on
sera toujours limité à 33 7% la limite
de chocs les crises à d'autres
technologies prometteuses comme les
cellules à perros qui tout le multi
couches sont malheureusement trop
toxiques ou trop coûteuses en réalité
les plus gros progrès ne sont pas faire
sur les panneaux mais surtout ce qu'il
ya autour d'abord le solaire n'est pas
que photovoltaïque il existe par exemple
le solaire thermique plane miroirs qui
concentrent le soleil vers une tour qui
contient du sel fondu 35 pour son
rendement c'est excellent et puis le
sait font du reste chaud même la nuit ce
qui limite l'intermittence au maroc ils
ont installé un demi million de miroirs
qui produisent assez d'électricité pour
six cent mille personnes la plus grande
installation est actuellement à il veut
même pas aux états unis très
impressionnant sauf qu'il y a des
défauts pour que ça brille autant même
en plein jour
vous imaginez bien qu'il faut pas trop
s'en approcher un rayon de la mort d'air
brûlant qui tuent plusieurs milliers
d'oiseaux chaque année empêche de
porticcio reproduire et provoquent des
incendies les locaux ont pas l'air très
content surtout que c'est très mais
alors très coûteux à entretenir edf qui
croit quand même et veut lancer au maroc
une centrale solaire hybride
photovoltaïque thermodynamique qui sera
une première mondiale 2 les technologies
de stockage évoluent les batteries
lithium-ion utilisées dans le solaire
c'est pas top et nash polluants du riz
du faible on a déjà épuisé les
ressources en lithium de la terre et
c'est dangereux un peu de batterie c'est
quasi impossible à arrêter il faut donc
changer de technologie et on a plusieurs
pistes déjà une nouvelle génération de
batteries avec d'autres éléments en
espérant que ça marche ensuite le
pompage turbinage ou l'électricité sert
à faire remonter de l'eau en hauteur on
a juste à faire couler quand on en
attend sur le même principe qu'un
barrage et enfin qui fait le plus
fantasmer le stockage à l'hydrogène
actuellement transporter l'électricité
directement de la centrale solaire à ta
maison ça marche pas super bien
problèmes d'intermittence de saturation
pertes en cours de route etc ou
gargantuesque des infrastructures voilà
pourquoi certains veulent se servir de
l'électricité solaire non pas pour
l'envoyer dans des files mais pour
fabriquer sur place de l'hydrogène la
seule chose dont on a besoin c'est de
l'eau un kilo de hydrogène contient 40
mille watts 1 kg de batteries
lithium-ion 140 fois moins voilà
pourquoi certains rêvent de l'hydrogène
comme le futur pétrole qu'on mettrait
partout pour chauffer sa maison comme
faire rouler sa voiture le souci c'est
que l'hydrogène des le plus petit at
home de l'univers et ça se faufile
partout or s'il ya une fuite
t'es mort c'est super explosif et au
contact de l'air la réaction est très
exothermique pas sûr qu'on puisse
laisser ça aux mains du grand public
sans compter que la technologie n'est
pas complètement au point et comme pour
hitler on sait pas si ça sera un jour
viable on en arrive à la troisième piste
beaucoup plus optimiste sur le futur du
solaire il sera partout celle avantage
énorme de cette énergie elle est souple
on peut la placer où on veut imaginer
des routes solaire des fenêtres équipées
de panneaux solaires transparente les
panneaux souples qu'on pourrait mettre
sur les stores des magasins ou sur les
parasols des terrasses ces technologies
existent depuis toujours pas toujours au
point mais c'est prometteur alors bien
sûr il pourrait imaginer le monde depuis
zéro des villes où toutes les
interactions se réadapter à usage du
solaire
pourquoi le solaire est quand même
l'énergie du futur parce que ça reste
l'énergie illimitée que l'humanité se
devra dompter par exemple avec les
sphères de dyson où on mettrait en
orbite plein de panneaux qui nous
permettrait de récupérer directement
l'énergie à sa source pensez à la
conquête d'une planète comme mercure où
on pourrait rendre certains cratères
habitable et autonome en énergie grâce à
des panneaux en surface qu'ils ont eux
aussi sont solaire à des ss pas de
satellite pas de conquête spatiale pas
d'avenir sur terre non plus car viendra
un jour le pétrole et le gaz manqueront
et le royaume aussi sinon plus longtemps
le soleil l'eau et le vent saurons-nous
seule ressource si les projets de fusion
nucléaire venait à échouer
qu'on le dise cette vidéo bien que
sceptique n'est pas anti solaire ça n'a
aucun sens d'être contre le
photovoltaïque il en faut c'est obligé
et c'est même plus prudent pour l'avenir
simplement il ne faut pas être aveuglés
par les belles promesses ça n'est pas
encore tout à fait au point même si ça
le deviendra très prochainement c'est
sûr alors oui investissons massivement
dans cette énergie mais en priorité dans
la recherche dans le remplacement des
énergies fossiles et dans l'évolution
des infrastructures qui sera de toute
façon un jour nécessaire face à
l'urgence climatique
on peut déjà travaillé avec ce qui a
fait ses preuves dans un mix intelligent
en france étant depuis longtemps une des
productrices d'énergie les moins carboné
au monde c'est un choix de société dont
je vous laisse débattre en commentaires
j'ai pleuré les commentaires avec les
meilleurs arguments des france comme
ceux d' attaque la condition étant de
sourds s'est expliqué et respecter le
travail fournit pas de vous dit de la
merde et n'avoir aucun bon argument
derrière si vous voulez aller plus loin
il ya d'excellentes vidéo sur l'énergie
sur la plateforme où vont comprendre
c'est très complet très rigoureux et ça
a beaucoup aidé pour cette vidéo sachez
qu'on en fera d'autres du genre où on
parlera des défauts des différentes
énergies proposez-nous la prochaine que
vous souhaitez voir traiter voilà je
pense que le travail est complet si ça
vous a plu et que vous voulez nous
remercier pensez à partager la vidéo est
à vous abonner à l'est les amis
[Musique]